i was rooting for you we were all
rooting for you it's michelle from lab
muffin beauty science here chemistry phd
skincare nerd
and beauty marketing connoisseur the
inky list
are brand that i generally quite like
they're probably the main competitor to
the ordinary which i also quite like
both brands have lots of products and
there are lots of products from both
brands that work well on my skin
they're both also really budget friendly
and it's hard to hate
brands that are making skincare more
financially accessible
both brands are also quite sciencey in
their marketing so they put their
ingredient names front and center
and i think that's gone a long way
towards making everyone more comfortable
with using
synthetic chemicals that they might not
be able to pronounce very easily they
have sort of scary-ish names
the whole natural is better don't use
ingredients you can't pronounce thing
i think really took a blow thanks to
these brands
recently the inculis released a new
product the sacinic acid acne treatment
you've probably seen it all over social
media inky are really busting out the
marketing budget for this release
and honestly i like this product a lot
it's been working really well for
breakouts i've gotten i put it on
and overnight it does seem to calm down
a lot
but i'm finding the marketing around
this product kind of shady
and i'm going to explain why if you like
this sort of nerdy beauty content click
the like the subscribe and the
notification bell so you don't miss any
videos
so first off this is not a bad product
like i said it works really well on me
and i think there are very few truly bad
products on the market
but there is a lot of dodgy marketing
i've been blogging about beauty products
since 2011 so i've had a lot of time to
read the press releases about new
products and i've gotten used to the
sorts of marketing tricks that brands
use
i'm not sure if it's intentional but the
marketing around the inculi-sacinic acid
acne treatment
is kind of genius let's start by talking
about sacinic acid
sacinic acid is usually used as a ph
adjuster or chelating agent in products
so it's playing a supporting role
it's not really an active it has almost
no peer-reviewed studies on it for acne
there are two papers on pubmed where
sacinic acid and acne are both mentioned
and they're from the same research group
the 2016 paper isn't actually really
about satinic acid
the 2014 paper is the one where they
actually did studies on it
basically staphylococcal epidermidis
bacteria compete with
sea acne's bacteria on your skin neither
of them are really good or bad
they both contribute to acne but they
both also protect your skin against
infections from other microbes they both
live inside acne pimples
and they're battling each other sacinic
acid is one of the chemicals that the
staph bacteria might be using
to keep the c acne's bacteria in check
the researchers put sacinic acid with c
acne's bacteria on one of these glass
plates they found that they needed a
concentration of five millimolar to kill
the bacteria
for comparison they needed twice as much
lactic acid and fifty percent more
acetic acid acetic acid
is the acid that you find in vinegar
then they injected sea acne's bacteria
into mouse ears to make them inflamed
like a pimple would be
then they injected sacinic acid into
them and they found that both the number
of bacteria
and the inflammation decreased finally
they decided to skin care some mouse
ears so they injected the c
acne's bacteria again and then they
applied about one percent sacinic acid
onto them
and they found that again the bacteria
counts and the inflammation decreased
now this is pretty promising but this is
far from enough evidence to say that it
actually works against
acne as a drug ingredient if you're
familiar with medicinal chemistry then
you'll know that there are millions and
millions of compounds that
work well on cells and on animals but
then
they never turn out to be a drug because
things that work well in cells and
animals
don't necessarily work well on humans in
real life the conditions on your skin
are very different from the conditions
on glass or on
an animal that's why you read about
cures for cancer being found in amazon
rainforests and then you never hear
about them again
it's not because big pharma is
suppressing the information it's because
that headline is based on in vitro or
animal studies
and it never actually got tested on
humans that's why the just says a mice
twitter account exists
there's also data from the chemical
company that sells the sacinic acid to
brands showing that it decreases sebum
but there are basically no details on
how the study was done and a lot of
supplier studies are
pretty low quality so they'll have
really small sample sizes
and sometimes the protocols are a bit
rigged in the ingredients favor
so it doesn't tell us much the inculus
marketing material also says that
sacinic acid has been in european
medical circles for a while
now this has been repeated in a lot of
magazines but
it's a really ambiguous statement and i
haven't heard back from inculist about
what that
actually means i don't think it means
that it's being used by european doctors
to treat their patients for acne i've
asked a few germs and they've said
they've never heard of it
and we saw the complete lack of evidence
before in the pubmed search results
so based on all of this it isn't really
surprising that no one's heard of
sacinic acid before
clearly no big brands are excited enough
about it to put it as the star
ingredient in their products
a lot of ingredient checker sites don't
even have a listing for it inky have
chosen an ingredient that they pretty
much have a monopoly on
this is nothing new a lot of brands do
choose ingredients that no one else is
using because then there's a novelty
factor and they can get people excited
about their particular product
and putting ingredients into products
that don't have a lot of evidence behind
them again is nothing new
it happens all the time and in general i
think it's a good thing if
everything had to be tested properly
then we would all be using about three
products
to me the big difference is that this
product is actually regulated as a drug
in the us
if you turn the packaging over you can
actually see the drug facts label
that's why inky are allowed to have the
word acne
in the name of their product front and
center acne is a medical condition and
you're only allowed to make products
that claim to treat medical conditions
if they're drugs
so this is an over-the-counter drug just
like sunscreen you don't need a
prescription to buy it
but it has a special status it has this
special status because it contains an
ingredient that's been scientifically
vetted to work
and that ingredient is salicylic acid
which is over here in size 4 font
on the legally required label it's up
here it's got top billing
whereas sacinic acid is over here
under inactive ingredients
but you wouldn't know it if you're
looking at the product name the product
packaging
the description of the product all the
marketing around the product
how everyone is talking about it whether
it's the beauty media sponsored
influences or unsponsored influences
sacinic acid is always talked about like
it is the top active ingredient that's
treating the acne
and not the actual active ingredient
it's called the lead ingredient
salicylic acid is supporting this sort
of marketing around fluff ingredients
is pretty basic standard misleading
beauty marketing 101 that you learn
about the moment you start getting into
skincare
it's where brands put a tiny sprinkle of
exotic jamaican sparkle flower
into their product and then you turn it
over and it turns out it's full of
retinol
but it doesn't happen a lot with actual
skin care drugs and i don't know if it's
because people realize that this would
be pretty deceptive
it's like a drug claiming it's a herbal
painkiller and you flip it over and it
actually has codeine in it or if you
have a sunscreen that calls itself a
mineral sunscreen
and then in size for font it has
oxybenzone and avobenzone
actually that analogy doesn't work that
well because at least zinc oxide is an
actual approved sunscreen filter so
let's do raspberry oil there are lots of
people who genuinely think that
raspberry oil is a good sunscreen
because in one in vitro study with a
dodgy protocol
it came out with an spf of 28 to 50. so
it's like a sunscreen that calls itself
a raspberry oil sunscreen
but it also has standard amounts of
oxybenzone and avobenzone in it
on the front the oxybenzone and
avobenzone is in size full font
but the marketing is all about how
amazing raspberry oil is for sun
protection it's the next big thing
lots of doctors in europe have been
using it for decades and then it says
there are these supporting players
avobenzone and oxybenzone now inky may
genuinely believe that sacinic acid is
amazing for acne
and it is the star player and maybe it
is the star player
but they're not legally allowed to say
that the level of evidence for sacinic
acid doesn't let them say this
i mean it's a pretty interesting
ingredient but with no
peer-reviewed studies that have actually
used it on human skin
it's pretty dodgy that it's being
marketed like it's a drug
that is less evidence than a lot of
ingredients that we think are sort of
fluffy so things like pecutial
and snail secretion those actually have
multiple peer-reviewed studies
on human skin to do it properly inky
should be submitting sacinic acid for
proper drug approval
so this involves rigorous trials on
human skin rather than just on 10
malseas
if they do that then sacinic acid can
join salicylic acid in that top box
but obviously this is very expensive but
they're in a loophole where it's a sort
of gray area and they don't actually
have to do this
because everyone's already assuming that
sacinic acid is a drug
that it is actively treating acne
sacinic acid is on the packaging right
next to the word acne
it's impossible to miss and you can see
that this marketing is working really
well if you look at articles in the
beauty media
succinic acid is the acne ingredient you
should be using
sacinic acid is not an acne ingredient
this specific product
is an acne treatment because it has
salicylic acid but that doesn't mean
all of the ingredients in this are acne
ingredients they don't have the level of
evidence for that
that's why they're in the bottom box
with the label inactive ingredients
i wouldn't be anywhere near as annoyed
if inky just changed the name of their
product and changed
the marketing a bit so that salicylic
acid was less of an afterthought
let's say they called it the triple
threat acne treatment with salicylic
acid sacinic acid and sulfur
not all of their products have a single
ingredient in the name so why didn't
they do that
maybe they wanted to highlight how great
they think sacinic acid is but
maybe it's actually the cleverest part
of this at the moment inky have a
monopoly on sacinic
acid no one else uses it as their star
ingredient and no one snuck it into a
drug product by using a different
active drug ingredient the way this is
played out is that people hear that
sacinic acid is great for acne they
google it
and conveniently the only product that's
made for acne with sacinic acid
is the inky list one if they use
salicylic acid as the headline
ingredient then you would come up with
tons and tons of products
but because no one else is doing this
then inky have basically made sure that
all of this traffic searching for
sacinic acid ends up
with this product even if it ends up
promoting misinformation
i don't know if inky are marketing
geniuses or they accidentally stumbled
onto this strategy but it is working
really well
step one make a product that's
classified as a drug because of
well-tested ingredients that every other
brand is already using
step two put the medical condition in
the name of the product next to a
little-known ingredient
the less evidence for it the better
because you'll have a search monopoly
step 3 promote the crap out of the
product you barely have to exaggerate
because the product name does it for you
every media outlet or influencer who
talks about the product has to say the
name and that ingrains that relationship
between the ingredient and the medical
condition in
everyone's minds step 4 profit i suspect
a lot of brands are going to try to copy
this because
it is working so well for inky that's
why i decided to make this video even
though i realized it might be a bit
controversial
so we can spot brands doing this in the
future and call them out
again i don't know if this was actually
their intention but the net effect is
that everyone is being led to believe
that sacinic acid
is an evidence-backed ingredient for
treating acne it is
an actual drug that treats a medical
condition and for me the worst part is i
really like kinky list
i really resonate with their values i
really like their emphasis on knowledge
and education
and it is a perfectly good product it
works really well everyone is gushing
about it it didn't need this
i was rooting for you we were all
rooting for you so in conclusion this
is a good product but it has bad
marketing it's misleading maybe it's not
intentionally deceptive but that is the
overall effect
so that's what i think i don't know what
are your thoughts let me know in the
comments what do you think about inky
list what do you think about this
specific product and the marketing
i hope you liked this video if you did
click the thumbs up and the subscribe
you can also follow me on instagram and
check out my blog for more beauty
science
see you next time to note out more